[Music]
hey conan o'brien here i'm still in the
same crappy office but now i've got
almonds
and
i'm on level four of angry birds listen
to those birds man they are angry
anywho that's not what i'm here to talk
about okay i'm here to talk about my
show on november shut up i'm here to
talk about my show i'm sorry i'm here to
talk about my show
on november 8th on tbs okay it's coming
up very soon and uh probably a lot of
questions out there people want to know
what's going on so if you want to ask me
a question ask the question and i will
answer you in another video all you have
to do is go to facebook.com
teamcoco and i will try to answer your
question here to demonstrate how it
works is aaron blair aaron asked me a
question hey conan what's your favorite
color i don't have a favorite color
okay it's that simple facebook.com slash
teamcoco i'll try and answer your
questions in the meantime
i have got to drop an egg bomb
on a pig
ring a crown with a walrus mustache
i'll see you soon
[Laughter]
what's the matter pig don't like being
dead